letzte woche habe ich dieses video hier
gemacht das problem mit selbstfahrenden
autos
es ging darum wann und vor allem ob
selbstfahrende autos den menschen am
steuer komplett ersetzen können
wenn ihr euch das video nochmal
anschauen wollt dann findet ihr unten in
der video beschreibung einen link dazu
aber wir müssen es nicht gesehen haben
um das video jetzt hier zu verstehen
einen aspekt den ich nämlich bewusst aus
dem letzten video raus gelassen habe ist
das problem
es ist ein philosophisches dilemma aus
dem jahre 1967 das versucht durch eine
extreme situation antworten auf ethische
fragen zu bekommen
eine version des klassischen dilemma es
geht so ein zug hat die kontrolle
verloren und rast auf fünf menschen zu
die auf dem gleis stehen
sie bemerken den zug nicht und würden
sterben wenn nichts weiter unternommen
wird du hast aber die möglichkeit die
weichen umzustellen und den zug auf eine
andere strecke zu bringen auf der sich
nur eine person befindet legst du nun
den schalter um und hört es damit aktiv
einen menschen oder machst du nichts und
sie ist sowie fünf menschen sterben in
letzter zeit für dieses klassischen
dilemma immer häufiger auf die moderne
technologie der selbstfahrenden autos
angewandt ein computer hat er innerhalb
von kürzester zeit millionen
kalkulationen durchführen kann kann
schließlich auch die personen vor sich
erkennen und eine entscheidung treffen
die die programmierer des autors vorher
festlegen können also so der gedanke
müssen wir uns heute schon überlegen wir
in vielen jahren vielleicht einmal von
selbst fahrenden auto umgefahren wird
und wir leben darf bei der recherche zum
letzten video habe ich diese studie von
media lab gefunden
über zwei millionen menschen aus über
200 ländern haben an der studie
teilgenommen und sie damit zu einer der
größten sozialen studien aller zeiten
gemacht die teilnehmer haben
verschiedenste szenarien des problems
durchgespielt bei jedem level muss man
entscheiden wer stirbt und wer das leben
sind fünf babys mehr wert als fünf
ältere ärzte sollten menschen die im
auto sitzen eher dran glauben als
fußgänger auf der straße was ist wenn
diese fußgänger über rot gegangen sind
die ergebnisse der studie sind ziemlich
interessant generell scheinen die zwei
millionen teilnehmer so viele
menschenleben wie möglich retten zu
wollen
opfern lieber tiere als menschen und
lassen junge menschen ihr leben als also
es gab aber auch unterschiede zwischen
den ländern
man fand zum beispiel heraus dass in
japan oder taiwan regelkonforme menschen
besonders geachtet wurden
deutschland kanada und die usa
präferierten er die dinge so zu lassen
wie sie sind und das auto seinen
ursprünglichen pfad entlang fahren zu
lassen und südamerikaner legten ein
fokus auf jüngere menschen und solche
mit hohem status in der gesellschaft das
problem mit dem trolley problem ist nur
dass es nicht wirklich realitätsnah ist
klar
der gedanke ist logisch die technologie
schreitet immer weiter voran
irgendwann ist ein computer in der lage
personen innerhalb von wenigen
millisekunden zu identifizieren aber in
der realität in der wir heute leben in
der bereits selbst fahrende autos über
unsere straßen fahren ist ein auto nicht
vorprogrammiert zwischen mehreren
objekten zu unterscheiden und bei einer
möglichen kollision eine entscheidung zu
treffen
ein selbst waren das auto macht heute
genau das gleiche wie wir menschen
sobald es ein objekt wahrnimmt tritt es
auf die bremse und versucht sein
möglichst es eine kollision zu vermeiden
fragt man echte experten was sie zum
quali problem sagen dann hört man
meistens seufzer sebastian tun der
ehemalige chef des google safe drive in
car project sagt zum beispiel folgendes
i think it's great thing for those of us
to discuss discover bremst bei der snort
of practical wie managed server wiki zu
helfen
mit traffic distant worlds denn für das
extreme iwh udo heppe fertig und billig
des kaspers of trophies denn meine
kleine henry ist wie mental energy der
flosse respekt und das casting ist
komplett die europäischen david peter
weiss ist man dann proben in der liga
der welt ein selbst fahrendes auto das
in der lage ist menschen zu
identifizieren und sie vielleicht sogar
nach alter geschlecht sogar nach
sozialem status facebook freunden und
vielleicht sogar schulden bei der bank
zu unterscheiden
das sollte doch gar nicht erst in die
situation kommen mehrere menschen
umbringen zu müssen
und selbst wenn dann passiert das so
selten dass es nicht nur extrem
schwierig sondern auch ineffektiv wäre
dafür regeln zu schreiben
stattdessen so sagen experten lenken
diese philosophischen fragen so
interessant sie auch sind vom
eigentlichen thema ab denn es stehen
sehr wohl menschenleben auf dem spiel
jeden tag sterben weltweit über 3.000
menschen in verkehrsunfällen
beinahe die hälfte davon sind dabei
nicht in einem auto sondern sind
fußgänger motorrad oder fahrradfahrer am
straßenverkehr teilzunehmen ist das
gefährlichste was die meisten von uns
jeden tag machen und für junge menschen
wie uns sind verkehrsunfälle sogar die
häufigste todesursache überhaupt selbst
waren autos können diese tode verhindern
die eigentliche frage ist nur wann sind
selbst fahren autos bereich für die
echte straße wann sollten wir sie
einsetzen sobald sie so gut sind wie wir
menschen oder müssen sie erst deutlich
sicherer fahren als wir menschen bevor
wir bereits sind die kontrolle abzugeben
im letzten video habe ich euch ja
gefragt wann ihr denkt das
selbstfahrende autos endlich auf die
straße kommen
mit über 600 kommentaren habt ihr alle
arbeit geleistet und wir haben mehr als
genug daten um eine schwarmintelligenz
zu bilden und so sieht das ergebnis aus
danke erst mal an honig aus dem neuen
doktor watson des quad channel der sich
die mühe gemacht hat alle kommentare per
hand einzutragen vielen dank für deine
ganze arbeit im durchschnitt seid ihr
der meinung dass selbst haben autos
irgendwann zwischen 2026 und 2027 auf
die straße kommen
ob es stimmt das werden wir dann sehen
übrigens es sind in letzter zeit viele
neue abonnenten hierauf doktor watson
dazugekommen schaut gerne mal bei mir
auch patron vorbei da könnt ihr viele
parks bekommen die euch vielleicht
interessieren
bald neu dabei ein exklusiver petra
channel auf dem desktop server vielen
dank an alle leute die uns heute schon
auf kathrin unterstützen ihr macht die
videos hier möglich danke an euch und an
alle die zugeschaut haben vielen der
krise schauen und wie immer bleibt
neugierig
[Musik]